samedi le mythique jeu d'aventuré fort
boyard faisait son grand retour avec un
changement de taille l'absence des
tigres
plus de fait là en chair et en os mais
en animation 3d et si la plupart des
associations ont salué l'initiative sur
les réseaux sociaux les fans de
l'émission n'ont pas su contenir leurs
déceptions le bien qu'il y ait des horts
absolue en matière de maltraitance
animale mais tout de même considérer que
les tigres de fort boyard subissait le
même type de maltraitance voilà le
résultat on se tape des modèles 3d est
absolument affreux pourtant fort boyard
était l'un des derniers programmes à
intégrer des animaux dans son jeu
intervilles coucou c'est nous 40 degrés
à l'ombre et même à l'époque sur pépé mp
si nos amis les bêtes nous ont parfois
fait mourir de rire il est temps
désormais de les laisser en paix alors
êtes vous pour ou contre les animaux à
la télé
[Musique]
alors il ya une loi depuis 2011 qui
comprend plusieurs mesures pour lutter
contre la maltraitance des animaux
domestiques et des animaux sauvages
captifs et améliorer leurs conditions de
détention et à partir de 2023 on ne
pourra plus y avoir dix fois puis vint
d'animaux sauvages dans les émissions de
variétés ou de jeter des médiums
télévision et la même date l'activité
des montreurs d'ours et de loups sera
interdite ça c'est pour la loi vous ça
va être terminé alors pour ou contre
vous vous êtes pour oui alors moi je
suis pour mais je pense que c'est même
pas le débat c'est est ce qu'il faut
bien traiter les animaux ont pas la
question ne se pose pas ou alors c'est
un jeu c'est pas le débat évidemment est
tous d'accord qu'il faut bien appeler
les animaux c est ce qu on doit
interdire mais il est en contact avec
son banc oui mais les divisions la
question et lé lé n est pas comme ça il
faut la poser il faut
quelques grognards
[ __ ] je dis oui
merde je dis oui parce que les animaux
doivent être bien traité donc s'ils sont
bien traités et ken émission pourquoi
pas pourquoi pas
mais leur place alors les animaux qui
sont là ok on les remet de mer dans la
jungle est-ce qu'ils vont se débrouiller
mais non mais c'est lancé
s'ils sont à la télé qu'ils sont là mais
qu'ils sont bien traités où est le
problème
certes ils vont mourir dans la nature
avoir un super alors elle a raison mais
non il est donc pour l'interdiction des
animaux la télévision non je sais pour
leurs animaux et à la télé pour les
d'accord s'ils sont bien traités c'est
ça c'est tout d'accord c'est tout vous
vous êtes comment toi michel arotce
absolument contre moi de façon je suis
contre appartement où sont fait faire
aux animaux des choses qu'ils sont elles
sont pas naturels je suis content je
suis content des animaux dans les eaux
compte dans les parcs aquatiques contre
dans des élevages intensifs etc je suis
pour les aliments naturels même s'il ya
des espèces qui doivent mourir c'est le
cycle de la vie comme ça ils
disparaîtront d'autres arriveront mais
on maintient pas des animaux en
captivité comme ça je chope souvent
contre la requête faite pour les pour le
cinéma par exemple pourquoi faire pour
le cinéma yahia plaindra vous faites
comme le roi lion de disney vous faites
de la 3d on a l'impression que ce sont
des vrais lions de voûte a pas besoin
d'aller fabre et alors qu'on sait le roi
lion produit pas aimer 5 millions de
dollars ça passe t'as pas quand c'est
dans fort boyard le tigre mesquine en
espagne où ils l'ont fait en famille
beaucoup donné c'est quelqu'un de chez
marc singer
là ressemble à rien qu'ils allaient
retirer copé de regarder les unions 3d
de fort boyard c'est horrible
soir après soir et nous accomplirons
notre vengeance
trésor ne tombe
l'esprit des tigres sera toujours avec
nous
alors vous poser une question mais
quitte à internet les animaux dans fort
boyard pourquoi on laisse les araignées
pourquoi on laisse les serbes attendez
quoi la série connaissent les rats
bâton est la suite logique allait
déchaîner n'ont pas de carnon pas de
sentiments effectif alors ça c'est nîmes
oui on mais nous les animaux alors si on
les enlève ça mais ça s'est passé où
j'avais aux nuances michel râtelle
traiterions est la seule différence
jean-pascal que si elle n'est pas fort
boyard il y aurait des araignées dans le
fort et pas gens de fort boyard yeux pas
de tigres en en force et une petite
différence quand même tu vois mais si on
les avait tous les élèves tous mais
c'est leur habitat naturel et les
fourmis dans les rucks où les bides
aérostiers les bons les serpents dans
les bras les mains chaudes on peut très
bien vivre sans et je comprends pas le
pourquoi il on est obligé de faire cette
image terrible de chats malades la
bizarre les enfants tête aime bien ce
genre d'animation c'est une émission
[ __ ] pour jean marie catrou r je crois
que les tic était plutôt très bien très
bien huilé très bien
sûr et tout est l'essence même de cette
émission est un moment là non tu y es tu
regardais les messages je disais à
l'enquêté s'était passé quel est le
message allez pour voilà elle a le droit
d'être contrôlé l'émission de télé
spécial g pour le déboulonner télévision
d'ailleurs madame en moi j'ai rêvé à
l'airé voyant deux décennies mme des
animaux à la télévision bien évidemment
que j'ai envie qu'il leur arrive rien
qui soit parfaitement traitée mais moi
j'ai envie de rêver et certaines
émissions les émissions et à des animaux
mais j'ai plus envie de les regarder si
des animaux n'y sont plus alors soit
vous me dégager des émissions mais si
vous me laissez pas reparu trente
millions d'amis sans animaux c'est
chiant
[Rires]
bah oui non mais ça change mais c'est
vrai que nenni tu dois laisser les
araignées tadegnon tu dois laisser les
gnons talent mais zidane et des animaux
voilà à la télévision alors une approche
pédagogique comme à l'époque du club
dorothée avec le dr klein ou encore les
lombards sorcier ouais voilà ça me pose
pas de problème
il ya un vrai souci est d'ailleurs la
loi est la loi et un serveur où il
serait de faire parler d'elle alors et
c'est vrai que les tigres ont donné des
séquences cultes dans fort boyard
rappelez vous de jean baptiste giabiconi
dans celui qui dans sa petite voiture tu
rêves pavillon le tigre l'aimé bien à
tel point qu'il lui a uriné dessus
les mosellans s'il vous plaît si
opérable ces bons
avoue rigoler tout le monde j'ai peur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais la peur sont dégonflés
alors vous vous êtes pour magali berda
oui moi je suis pour parce que déjà je
me dis ces lions là on sait qu'ils
étaient bien traités moi je suis
confiant
excusez moi
alors c'est le jeu c'est sort que la
roma d'air
ils étaient bien traités mais maintenant
ils sont où les pauvres ça se trouve ils
sont maltraités maintenant en fait
ça ne sont pas les
voir là parce que je sais que la
production d'alexia laroche-joubert des
gens qui sont très sérieux qui font pas
n'importe quoi et franchement
j'y suis allé j'ai des buses avait l'air
heureux l'époque citons dire
par le tigre aussi grosse habite pas là
oui on est ensuite
on sait pas du tout ce qui peut leur
arriver aussi enfin il ya des espèces
qu'il faut préserver qu'il faut faut y
faire attention malheureusement pas ce
qui se passe plein de choses aussi
jacoby digue est justement sur
ça va me retire après avoir discuté avec
le trailer est en étroite collaboration
avec france télé ils vont consacrer une
somme d'argent jusqu'à la fin de leur
vie pour qu'ils puissent vivre dans les
meilleures conditions c'est toi
[Musique]
c'est qu'on prend un joli contrôle des
animaux la télé parce que
ça rend con trats jamais tu as arrêté un
jour on voit alors moi j'ai des photos
de vacances avec vous on va les voir
parce que c'est un élément
incontournable pour l'audience de fort
boyard donc juste arrêté ils ont rien à
faire là au milieu moment de saint-fort
est-ce que c'est pas le lieu naturel où
ils doivent les entretiens les les
vachettes d'intervilles la
normale en temps je connais elle va vous
explique les vachettes d'intervilles
c'est fou
mais reconnaissez que quand on était
petits qui ont gardé un terminé convoyer
avec surpiqûres par les vachettes on
rigolait beaucoup bien sûr et regardez
les images
[Musique]
seulement
cette appris en bande
s'est quand même imposé non là non je
vois rien sinon
je suis pas je suis partagé parce que
moi mon adolescence était bercé par
dechavanne et donc au coup c'est nous ou
ilaina louis van gaal dont cinq ans au
sein de choses il ya
plein de gens vous rappelez des ours
avec des chamallows way regardez c'était
génial bah ouais mais j'adore j'adore tu
aimes les yeux et hummer la bouche tu la
sortie d'un premier contrat est de faire
baisser votre nom vous reste à savoir
quel degré de bouc
[Applaudissements]
avec les animaux parce que c'est pas
bien on peut pas mettre les enfants
parce que paient pour les enfants qui
est très bien on peut pas rigoler ou pas
dire des gros mots on peut pâtir des
ensuite on peut pas on peut on peut
parier à monster
donné on pourra peut en fait un peu tout
et
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on s'est battu pendant qu'on prend pas
un seul risque avec de chabaneix donc
pour que luz course sans sur le plateau
comme ça on lui arrache les riffs avant
il a pu de griffe et oui
pendant les siens ont les piquets de
grève se sont plus rennais mais
bien voulu parler d'arrêt pas naïf
rappelez-vous sur le plateau de 50 de la
longue je crois c'était avec ou 40
degrés à l'ombre sa
démission était de 150 ans avec leur
carrière ni y avait un petit jeu vous
dire que vous avez relais
auprès des coupes et parce qu'il ya
laissé la moitié du bras regardez alors
soyons pas naïfs qui est fêté son petit
lion oui c'est bien quantitié quel âge
il ya 16 mois
voilà voilà la [ __ ]
donc une petite
caisse n'est pas quoi faire mais oui son
cabinet mais oui voilà en titi donc à 16
mois il a donc sauté sur sur sur mariage
et ça se passe pas très bien
je vous explique pendant les images et
jean midi basset mairie pour l on peut
pas dire sachant mm à l'arrière
n'y avait pas de griffes ne soit pas il
n'avait pas de griffes on y est relevé
mais tu rigoles jeu c'est un moyen de 75
je disposerai jamais le toréador qui se
fait planter par un taureau c'est
qu'on n'est pas là on parle pas de ça tu
as raison on va passer un peu le même
truc tu joues pas les animaux sauvages
mais sauvages
animales
et encore il faut pas s'étonner qu'il y
ait de ce genre de réaction bien sûr le
matin au mexique et ses dents d'animaux
se balade sauvage donc plus d'animaux
oui très bien je pense que cette loi qui
est qu'ils arrivent justement pour
supprimer les animaux tout ça je pense
que de toute façon elle est très bonne
parce que c'est vers quoi on se dirige
et il faut voilà moi je suis d'accord
mais c'est tout l'inversé
korydallos fois que j'ai dit que j'étais
pour la corrida parce que c'est ma
culture etc oui et je sais que ça va
s'arrêter et c'est une bonne chose mais
mais j'aime ça et ça va s'arrêter là ça
va s'arrêter ce film c'est
comme de tels joueurs rappelez vous la
rencontre entre christophe dechavanne
aller et là autant pas ça c'était génial
encore grave donc pongo pygmaeus ce qui
veut dire qu'en indonésie un homme des
bois
[Rires]
je
ne connais pas du tout d'abord je suis
malade il a juste mon cou dans sa main
et les garçons comme un camion un
nom du genre supply chain la police
comment est dix fois plus puissant à oui
c'est une puissance très élevé à 871 en
fait il est pas il n'est pas
fou il n'est pas conscient de sa force
[Applaudissements]
je ne sais pas d événement auto mais
voilà c'est bien été levée oui notre
génération dont sac est malade sinon on
a été élevé au cirque moi tout
est illuminé on met une salopette doré
quand
on arrivera pas là on va terminer
séquence avec encore de chavannes et la
séquence de l'est font parce que voilà
ça en fait ça vous fait rire mais moi
oui ajoute à ça le fait marrer c'est
l'excusé mois alors autant que vous
d'être à poissons et puis
oui
c'est sûr que va descendre
qu'est ce qu'il fait là
monsieur si vous parlez de votre neveu
bt avec sa peine
aujourd'hui vous sent très investi je
vous laisse le mot de la fin c'est parce
que je serai que je parraine l'espérer
jeu un éléphant n'a pas à la pâte comme
ça pour le faire monter sur son dos il
sait des heures et des heures de torture
il n'y a pas d'autres mots pour leur
faire faire ce genre de geste pour se
mettre elle est belle et pâtes en eau
comme ça c'est de la torture cpt ont
fait 0 fait subir aux animaux d'iliad
régression positive aussi donc